welcome back hope you had a good easter
you know even in a decaying christendom
there is something so heartening about
sunday service on easter morn with the
church pews
packed as they rarely are and oh wait no
sorry that my mistake that was the old
easter
before the state rolled the stone in
front of the church door
so the hosannas were decidedly muted
yesterday
singing remains forbidden in california
churches
in spain they've taken the additional
precaution of banning hymnals
in greece they've banned loudspeakers
just in case you're tempted to hold an
outdoor service but really why not just
cut to the chase
in ireland all in-person services are
illegal
and like father hughes and muller horan
who said mass to 40 congregants
you'll get a 500 euro fine if you're
minded to try it
and pastor cronin at the abundant grace
church
in dublin was arrested mid-service
in one of posterity's little jests an
irish catholic is currently only free
to practice his religion if he heads
north across the border where under the
tyrannous british protestant yoke
the churches are open unlike down south
however don't get carried away what the
state giveth
the state can take away his british
coppers in south london
seizing the pulpit and closing down
worship in
mid-service it is good friday and i
appreciate you would like to worship
this gathering is unlawful so please may
you leave the building now
what's the proper response to that
here's pastor arthur pavlovsky
in calgary alberta please get out
get out of this property immediately get
out
get out of this property immediately
out i don't want to hear anything out of
this property immediately i don't want
to hear a word
out out out of this property
immediately until you come back with a
warrant
he called them nazis and the gestapo
preach it preacher man
and through the sheer power of his words
he drove the coppers down the stairs
like jesus throwing the money changers
out of the temple for it is written
my house shall be called the house of
prayer and ye are not going to make it a
den
of totalitarian goons the only people
committing a crime there
were her majesty's miserable and
unworthy calgary constabulary
who were in breach of section 176 of the
canadian criminal code
quote everyone who willfully disturbs or
interrupts an assemblage of persons met
for religious worship
is guilty of an offense punishable on
summary conviction
that's a slam dunk and that canadian
pastor should file a complaint with
oh the police there is a tragic
element to the diminished state of the
christian churches a year into this
thing if ever there were a huge
opportunity
for religious ministry a world in which
everything
else is dead movies shows sports
concerts restaurants
all the noisy distractions of the
secular consumerist life
is surely it yet for the most part
starting with the social justice pontiff
in the vatican blaming covid on climate
change
the churches blew it and saddest of all
an unchurched year has seen
church membership in the u.s fall for
the first time
below 50 percent of americans which is a
pity because when the churches fall
silent the only religion left
is the state